er hat dafür gesorgt dass in düsseldorf
keine masken mehr getragen werden muss
die masken pflicht seien laut antrag von
johannes engel hat rechtswidrig so hat
auch das verwaltungsgericht düsseldorf
am montag entschieden mit der begründung
es sei nicht eindeutig erkennbar wo und
waren die masken pflicht gilt am
dienstag soll das von der stadt eine
neue allgemeinverfügung geben
wegen der offenkundigen rechtswidrigkeit
dieser verfügung der stadt ist es gibt
viele punkte die in dieser verordnung
und klar sind und wegen dieser vielen
punkte ist auch die rechtswidrigkeit
festgestellt worden
also ich bin froh dass die masken
pflicht gekippt worden ist weil ich
finde es ehrlich gesagt lächerlich wenn
ich irgendwo auf der straße alleine und
10 20 meter weiter kommt mir eine
entgegen und ich musste mit einer maske
rumrennen doch mit dieser entscheidung
sind nicht alle bürger einverstanden
einige fürchten einen massiven ausbruch
der krankheit bei patienten mit
vorerkrankungen
ja was denn ich die verantwortung haben
sie diese leute genug
die meinungen zur masken pflicht und
gespalten aber ob sie bei der neuen
allgemeinverfügung am dienstag enthalten
sein wird ist unklar
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren